and very very important news demi lovato
has come out as
non-binary which is to say demi lovato
is exactly the same person that she was
three days ago just now demi lovato says
that she wants to be called they them
which is weird because she's not
separated into more than one human
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them
i feel that this special represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person i both know i am
and still am discovering let's just be
straight about this it has
nothing to do with reality this has to
do with subjective self-perception
you can't officially change your
pronouns because there is no box that
you check
that you have officially now changed to
your pronouns and even if there were
there were
this would not change the realities on
the ground which is that you are not a
plural human being
nor are you quote unquote non-binary you
can't just decide that you're non-binary
one day